[Music]
so we don't have a lot of time left but
um we talked about you mentioned
pay-per-view buys
awesomic room
has got to be one of the dumbest people
ever
why i checked out our last vid uh the
video from our lawyer oh yeah
by the way spencer's our lawyer yeah
he's our lawyer
he doesn't know that but
he is our lawyer yeah he might not even
be a lawyer but he's our lawyer yeah
um
so you know spencer cornelia
he did this 18-minute video i forgot to
watch this i watched it
dude
dude
rip off your feet and [ __ ] your ass
austin mcbroom is crazy we have a
serious problem
bro
this it's 18 minutes and basically
spencer you know does does us a solid
and he provides us legal counsel like he
always does but he always does
and he takes out select clips from this
live stream
where
the live it's so it's live by live not
live x live but like the ceo
kind of goes publicly and and he's
talking about different things and it's
obviously to cover on the [ __ ] loss
of value that they've had and they sort
of tell like their side of it and
it's it opens up a lot because
it's not that live by live was
necessarily trusting of austin it's that
they saw potential
and there was a point where even as the
thing was burning up in flames
they made austin an offer to partner
with social gloves
essentially make the debt go away and go
look
we see a future here we'll cover off
on the loss and we'll invest more money
and we'll do another one and we'll make
it bigger and we'll learn how to profit
from it they were fully down to do a
[ __ ] partnership for 10 years or some
[ __ ] after the first fight went down yes
after that event happened they were like
you know what it was just marketed
poorly
the execution wasn't right but beca he
was like dude
wait wait so hold on just so i get this
clear
they basically were like hey we'll cover
the losses as in we will get the
fighters paid
it was more or less that okay more or
less that was the idea because
the ceo of live by live says dude
no one for their first pay-per-view
event has ever sold that many
pay-per-views for a first-time event
he's like that is unprecedented that is
crazy
so for live by live it wasn't a loss it
was like
oh dude we have something we just need
to figure out what it is but we got that
many people in on the first one
we can figure this out
and so now where it's at is
dog
the money is like held up in an escrow
account
and it seemed so the most egregious
thing first
uh that you find out is that austin
signed all these contracts with bryce
the taylor holder with whoever
and he all gave them a first position so
they're all signed the contract thinking
that they had first position on the
money that's illegal obviously not all
of them can have first position so live
by live ceo is like that you could say
that's fraud
he's like i don't know what the rules
are but that pretty much seems like
fraud because he frauded three people
into thinking whatever right
and then what's even shadier is austin
gave himself first position okay so with
the way it breaks down the live by live
ceo and they're like dude we're trying
to get clarity and his lawyers and stuff
will not release the contracts they
won't give us information
so live by live ceo speculating that
austin is trying to find a way with his
legal team to get that first position to
get his five million dollars
they offer to put marketing dollars in
to market it to to go uh to earn money
off of pay-per-view through tv
first of all austin declined
offering pay-per-view through television
why
he oh cause um i think it was
there was like a cost associated with
that right and he was like no we don't
need it yeah
and so spent you know
shout out to our lawyer his his
assessment was like austin's clearly
broke because he doesn't want to give
any money up he was trying to do this so
that there were no costs and there's
just like a paycheck that comes back
um and then the live by live ceo i was
like dude literally 98 of pay-per-view
buys come from television he's like
that's that's just fact
so you literally
alienated 98 of your potential sales
because that's what they do right they
put on pay-per-view yeah yeah
um
so he did that and also austin's like a
dumb ass because if he wanted all that
attention if they're gonna put marketing
dollars behind it they're talking about
like trying to hit that middle 30
percent they're trying to blow it up
like a conor mcgregor event yeah
if if you knew you're gonna beat the
brakes off of bryce wouldn't you want to
do that in front of like millions of
people
yep like that's where he's a [ __ ] like
he could have
you know unfortunately
you know
i say unfortunately because no one would
want to see this but he could have won
over this whole new audience of people
who didn't don't know anything about him
they don't they're not privy to his
shittiness they just know him
as a dude from youtube who can kind of
box and he beat the [ __ ] out of this guy
and that was a pretty good event
yeah but to him it's not that it's oh no
clearly he's like no we have all the
marketing power we need
yes look at the people we're working
with followers equates to yeah
product purchases yeah and
and also i don't want that cost
that's going to take away one of my
private jet rides yeah next two years or
whatever yep so
where they're at now is austin
it's it's like one of two ways
one way is austin ties everyone up in
court
and then they start dipping into the
earnings to burn out
uh to pay for lawyer fees and then no
one gets paid okay but here's the crazy
part is that james harden was given on
hit on paper a minimum guarantee okay
so he has to be paid two mil
so that either has to come out of the
live by live money
and what live by live is doing is
they're saying we won't pay james until
you give us the waterfall so we know how
much to pay taylor how much it's paid
bryce yeah because they're trying to get
people paid right because they're trying
to do right by them right
and if austin drags it out so that all
that money gets burned up in court and
no one gets any james harden's still
entitled to that money so he can go
after austin personally oh wow so the
live i live dude is like
you know
he's going to learn a hard lesson
because he might just have to start
selling cars and they're going to take
his house and
james he's like that minimum guarantee
really complicates things because uh
that means he has to be paid
damn that's wild
so it like
and what's crazy is this is not being
talked about like by anybody except him
and
this fool might like go up in [ __ ]
flame
like hard
yeah yeah
because it doesn't seem like his ego
will let him just like
go [ __ ] yeah there's no money
like rather than just walk away with a
zero and then just call it even he's
like straight up gonna put himself in a
position where he just loses everything
and no one will ever trust him or work
with him again no no his career is over
someone pointed out that his wife
started a separate youtube channel
and they're speculating that they're
trying to do that to try to shift all
the revenue outside of him
so that if he does burn up
the earnings are all through her yeah
and he's like well you know yeah you can
come after me personally
but i don't have anything jesus christ
grift that's crazy why doesn't she just
leave his ass
i no dude i think she's like
like they're both probably like trying
to you know whatever we're trying to
preserve this [ __ ] yeah because you know
that's crazy
yeah
so
sorry you know i had we had a long call
me and spencer yeah yeah yeah you know i
know i told me sorry i couldn't make
that call yeah yeah it's fine yeah we'll
catch up with him later yeah
um he's such a good lawyer
i mean it is one of those things where
people are like oh you don't wish ill on
anyone but god damn it if this [ __ ] did
not
like
if the writing wasn't on the wall for
this [ __ ] yeah and if this dude does not
get like what's been coming to him
it's crazy because everyone's
called it like we talked about it and
everyone feels the same way even in the
comments and him and he's like oh he
just did this to try to beat jake paul
to just say yeah like what a such a
narrow thing
i don't know man egomaniac
[ __ ] bro
i watched you know i got off the zoom
with spencer and i just have to say this
and i went to austin's uh
instagram and i like i'm like i wonder
what the [ __ ] he's doing he's just
posting selfies on a story
glib to all of it just like yeah
they consume me i don't give a [ __ ] yeah
i wonder what he has to be thinking
i don't think he thinks anything i think
he genuinely feels that there's a way
out
and he probably has a bunch of yes men
around him who are like yeah dude
you'll definitely beat this yeah you'll
definitely get your money
because because they have an incentive
to get that money anyways new social
gloves event this saturday